Welcome to the continuing
series of Academy Dialogues,
It Starts With Us.
We are continuing
our conversations
about race, ethnicity,
history, gender, opportunity,
and the art of filmmaking,
hosted by the Academy.
Moderating our conversation
today, arts and culture
journalist and radio host
Elvis Mitchell, in conversation
with Mexican director
and screenwriter
Rodrigo Garcia, casting director
Julia Kim, and veteran casting
director Victoria Thomas.
We look forward to
your conversation.
Thank you.
So here's the question I
want to start this off with.
Just because it's something
I've been thinking about, just
trying to figure out a
way to kick this off.
If there is a piece of
sort of colorless, color,
interesting color
casting that made
you have a hope for what
movies could be-- because I'll
tell you mine, for example.
Seeing Billy Dee Williams in
Tim Burton's Batman, because he
played Harvey Dent,
which made me think,
maybe he'll get
to play Two-Face.
And of course, he didn't.
But anyway, I just wondered
if there's something like that
that you guys saw in your lives
that made you think, well,
maybe movies-- because we get
so much of the information
about ourselves as people
in the world from movies.
So I just wondered if there's
any moment that occurred
to any of you guys like that?
The most-- it was a film called
Searching where John Cho played
a father, and it
had nothing to do
with him playing
an Asian character,
but really just about a father
whose concerns and worries
about his daughter were common,
no matter what color you were.
And that was a monumental
moment to see that breakthrough
occur in a major film.
I think it might be
obvious, but I mean,
I guess I would just
say Hamilton, where
the diversification
of that cast,
and obviously portraying
white characters
with Puerto Ricans or
black people, or whatever,
it kind of brought
a larger truth
to what they were trying to
do with the story of Hamilton
anyway.
So it didn't feel so
self-conscious to me,
because I think it was
getting at a bigger
truth about the
creation of our country.
So I mean, that would be kind
of an obvious one for me.
I think, generally,
you know, you're always
very thankful to see people
of color playing roles
that are unexpected
and that are not
about the ethnicity
itself, that don't have a--
I mean, some movies, of course,
speak about the ethnicity
itself.
But just like Julia
said, when a character
is everything at the same time.
I think to say
colorblind casting,
there's something
imprecise about it,
because who you are, including
your ethnicity and your color,
always means something,
and will mean something
to the character.
So it's when something
comes together
in a character for who they
are, but of course, there's
no denying also who they
are ethnically and racially.
I think those are the
characters that stand out.
I can't give you
examples because my brain
is at that stage now.
[LAUGHS]
We'll go off of that
stage into another stage.
But because what
we're talking about,
and what you said so
beautifully, Julia, is
that I think you
guys all want to do
is create a tone where casting
is subtext rather than text,
so we see these things,
and the identifiers
become the character
and [INAUDIBLE] as much
as the ethnicity, right?
Absolutely.
I think we're on that
kind of trend anyways.
I think we're seeing
more and more of it.
So it's really encouraging.
But there's probably still
more work to be done.
And I'm sure we'll
talk about it.
I mean, I hope we do,
because especially in light
of the recent Academy inclusion
changes for Best Picture,
I guess I want to get your
guys', get your takes on what
you thought when
you heard that news,
and what you think it
might mean for the future.
And let's start
with you, Rodrigo.
I mean, I think it was
an excellent measure.
It was overdue.
I think, obviously
it is of this moment.
But the Academy has been moving
in the direction of inclusion
over the last few years.
And I also think, you know,
there was a very good job done
of doing something
that's specific,
but also in its own
way also inclusive,
meaning it wasn't going
to shackle filmmakers.
There are many
ways to contribute
to moving in the direction
of inclusion and of diversity
without tying the hands of
filmmakers in such a way where
it would just be crazy.
I think it was done in
a very appropriate way.
And I think it was
going to yield results.
It better.
I'm sorry, go ahead.
Vicky, what were
you going to say?
Yeah, I thought--
I know there, beside the Best
Picture category requirements,
now, I thought the mentorship
and the internships
are a really important
part of instituting,
because people of
color don't necessarily
have either family backgrounds
being in the business,
or come from a line
of my dad was an AD
and my mom was a
costume designer.
It's not as frequent, I think,
in communities of color.
I did feel, I have to
say, when I saw the--
and I haven't read
it to the letter,
but when I saw the requirements
for Best Picture and the one--
the one actor of
color be in the--
yeah.
I just-- I said to
myself, what if I
want to nominate a
movie about the Amish?
I mean, that's-- I mean,
I kind of had a little bit
of a hesitation about that one.
I can speak to that, Elvis,
if I may, because I was,
like you mentioned,
I'm on the board.
So I was, you
know, at least part
of the final processes in that.
I think, you know, you read
precisely the one regarding
acting.
But I think that these
rules allow for you to--
for your production to have
inclusion in different areas,
that include everything from
casting to behind the camera
to the post-production to the
studio to the distributor.
There are many ways to do it.
And things were discussed
like you suggested.
Without betraying
anything, the example
did come up, well,
what if you're
making a movie in Iceland
about Icelandic people?
But I think the rules are
not loose, but broad enough
to include that.
And I think there
will also probably
be a process by which particular
examples can be addressed,
so that we don't end up
excluding that kind of movie.
I read it over, and I
applauded the effort.
I thought the requirements gave
a lot of space for flexibility.
And like you said, Rodrigo,
it's not just the acting part.
It's the material.
It's the key department heads.
It's the crew.
So the comments that I read
felt a little knee jerk
reaction oriented, but I
don't think the Academy
is looking to limit creativity.
I don't think the
Academy was looking
to look for reasons
to disqualify a film.
I think what they were trying
to do is spread the love.
And also, I think there
is a lot of diversity
and eclectic people entering
our business on a daily basis.
So I feel like you'd almost
have to find a reason
not to meet two out of the
four requirements in this day
and age.
But yeah, I think it's
a process in motion
with really good intentions.
Because what we're
talking about is,
we're talking from the top down.
It feels like there haven't
been that many changes.
But for you guys,
as creative people,
it feels like that world has
kind of always been open,
and is now just almost impatient
about saying, let's move
on to the next step.
Let's have John Cho play a dad.
And yet must not be the
first thing we learn
or the first thing that's
spoken about, literally,
because that's what happens.
So often characters of
color will basically
tell you in the first of
their lines, oh, by the way.
So as if the audience can't
actually suss this out.
And I'm wondering if that kind
of bedrock change of being
able to get people in
casts who get us past that,
and make these movie
look more like the world,
are even more wholesale than
they did even five years ago?
I think that it
needs to look more
like the world, what I see.
And I do see it.
I do see more of
what I see around me.
I mean, I was born and
raised in Los Angeles,
so diversity is not
a big thing for me.
It was part of my
natural environment.
So yeah.
I think, as Rodrigo
says, it's about time.
But I'm sure there's people
who are impatient and feel
like the incremental changes
aren't happening fast enough.
But I see a big change
from when I first started
in this business and to now.
I think television has been
a big instigator of change
a lot more than movies, and they
started earlier than movies.
And it's kind of almost a
mandate, in most television
just in diversifying
their casts.
So they've taken the--
they've taken this on and
really, really run with it.
I think, you know,
Elvis, I think especially
in the case of directors,
there's often that knee jerk
reaction, well, why can't
I do whatever I want to do?
You know, why can't I use
the people I want to use?
I mean, that's just
the kind of thing
that comes with the DNA
of being a director.
But again, I think
what I like about this,
and I'm now speaking
as a filmmaker.
I'm not speaking as someone
who is on the Academy board
and had somewhat
of a role in this.
You know, these rules
are also an invitation
for people to think differently.
What if this
character was Chinese?
What if this character was this?
You know, it's a little bit--
it sounds like medicine,
but it's an invitation
to think in a different way.
And I think that's
what can be valuable,
and that's where directors
can satisfy what we're trying
to do, but also satisfy
themselves that I'll do it,
but it needs to be
a Guatemalan person.
OK, well let it be
We have to find
that middle ground
between the creative impulse
and the creative vision
and what we're trying to do,
without as Vicky suggested,
making things impossible
for filmmakers.
I'm glad you brought that up
about directors kind of wanting
their own way, because it'll
give me a chance to ask
Vicky and Julian this question.
You can pretend to not hear.
Probably you'll answer this.
But when you are talking
with filmmakers who do
want things the way they want
them, and they aren't being--
[INAUDIBLE] they're
being stubborn
about what they think they
want, but your job is really
to expose them to ideas and to
actors they may not know about.
And does get to--
at what point did that get
to be easier from you guys
as casting directors to
say, well, look at him,
and not have
everyone go, well, I
didn't see an Asian or a
Black person in that role.
When did that really start to be
a noticeable change in the way
you guys work?
I think in the
last several years.
It used to be, I think,
a harder thing to change,
I think, back in the 2000s,
or the '90s, or back then.
But look, sometimes you
have to kind of come
through a different, a
side door with directors,
if they weren't thinking about
a certain character being
whatever, anything
different than what
they had fixed in their minds.
You just kind of try
to introduce someone,
you know, after they've
seen several of the type
that they're looking for, maybe
you kind of slip someone in,
and it's a little bit
different, and they kind of
get to hear it, and oh, OK,
I didn't think about that.
Or just try to kind of go
in a back backdoor in a way,
being respectful of what they
want, but also saying, here's
another way we
could possibly go.
So it's really just kind
of finessing a little bit,
kind of show them something
they might not have
thought of before, or you know?
Yeah.
It's part of our job,
I think, to do that.
So we first read the script
and meet with the director,
if it's someone we've
never worked with before,
and we hear their hopes
and dreams about it,
and get a good understanding
of what they're
seeking for these roles.
But then, I think, trust in
our ability to bring some fresh
ideas to the tables, and
out-of-the-box ideas.
If they veto it,
you know, you tried.
But I think it's our job
to expand their mind,
because a lot of
directors I work with
have written the
material as well,
and you become
very married to how
you've been thinking about it.
And I think that
casting directors
are super instrumental
in broadening
that sort of narrow
vision that they've
been carrying this whole time.
And yeah, I think that's why we
like what we do, right Vicky?
It can be difficult,
but as you said,
Julia, they get very
married to something.
I understand, it can
be a personal project.
It could be a script about
their life, or their family.
And so you want to respect that.
And if-- and hopefully,
whatever different option
you bring to them
helps accentuate
whatever they're trying to
communicate to an audience.
Well, I don't think
we're bringing
in color for color's sake.
I mean, I think like we
want the project to succeed,
and we have the goodness of the
project and the success of it
in mind with implementing some
of these out-of-the-box ideas.
Well, go ahead, Rodrigo.
I was just actually thinking,
while Vicky and Julia were
talking, that you know, I have
been in that situation, where
I'm the writer,
director, and sometimes
the casting director
will say, well, how
about Elvis Mitchell
for that role?
And I'm like, no, I just--
I love him, but I don't see it.
And you know, Elvis
Mitchell stayed on the list
and stayed on the list,
and they brought him up,
and they brought him up.
And I remember a couple
cases in particular
where one of the first
names I shot down,
and three months
later, it was her.
And she was great
that it was her.
And this was on a pilot,
not material I'd written.
But you know, that is where the
strengths of being a director
are so close to the weaknesses
of being a director.
You know, the tunnel vision.
And I think that's
where your heads
of department, and of
course casting, is crucial.
And yeah.
I've seen that.
Those names just stay on the
list and stay on the list,
and one day you're
like, OK, bring him in.
Just so you know,
I'm still waiting.
But anyway.
I was going to ask you, do
you guys, Vicky and Julia,
if it is that much
more difficult getting
these kinds of changes
or these kind of ideas,
like you were saying,
for writer directors,
so as you were
saying, Vicky, people
who have lived with this
thing and dreamed about it,
and been waiting
for years and years,
and it's like I voted
with these people in mind.
And sometimes, obviously,
you guys showed up to vote.
Well, that's a much more
interesting way to go.
But the writer
director way tends
to be that much harder
than just working
with somebody who's not a
writer on the project, who's
then directing.
No, they can rewrite it.
[LAUGHS]
They can go, wait,
Eureka, you actually
opened my eyes to
something kind of different
that I didn't think about.
Let me rework that character
to fit in this new introduction
that you kind of
presented to me.
So there is advantages to
working with writer directors
too.
I think, you know, in some
ways casting directors
are like editors in
the sense that they
know their job is so much
about process, meaning time.
You cannot edit a movie
in a week with 17 editors.
You need the 17 weeks.
And casting is the same.
You need to sleep on it.
Whoever excites you Monday
doesn't excite you Thursday.
And I think casting directors
have that incredible patience
and knowledge that
time will tell.
Yeah, very much so.
Oh, because it's
funny, because you're
saying that, Vicky, about
certain kinds of projects
demanding certain casts.
I guess I just find
myself thinking,
is this going to feel like
this new Best Picture thing,
because I've heard this
phrase from hanging out
with people so many times.
I want to get behind it.
People think it's the right
idea, and certainly an idea
whose time has long since come.
But also, just there
is the artistic ideal
that you can't force chemistry.
And then people will
resist for reasons
that, whether they be valid
or just kind of rationale
because they want to
stick their ground,
I wonder about having those
kinds of conversations
with directors and say, well,
at least be like this so you
it can feel like this.
I mean, I found myself
being the only black person
in the room arguing for
a character to be white,
just because I think
because it makes
kind of sense for a
certain power structure
that you're talking
about within the movie.
And I know, I love to
push for diversity.
I'm all for it.
But there are times when, yeah,
I was asking for the white guy,
just because it really kind of--
that casting, it's what the
project was talking about.
It's the sort of
power imbalances
that the project
was talking about.
So it just seemed to
make more sense that way.
So I guess I've had that
sort of conversation
that you maybe wouldn't
think I would be having.
And it was noted
by the producer.
I said, look, I just
think that's the right way
to go in this instance.
No, no.
That's interesting,
because, I mean,
I think one thing
is people of color,
we bring to this
kind of thing, is
that we bring a point of
view that's not often had.
And I guess where we're getting,
and what you guys are talking
about, and you're doing so well
here, is that point of view,
and exercising it.
And I guess if that's something,
[INAUDIBLE] Rodrigo, if you're
having these conversations
about trying to create
a kind of a chemistry.
The directors, especially a
writer director, perhaps, I
don't know, is really
wedded to the idea of it
needs to be this, and you
would then just try to say,
well, let's think
about this in terms
of the kind of social
fabric it creates.
I don't cast a film for
social, like you know--
I cast a film with the
success of the story,
and the meat of what is being
the director's intention
at the heart.
So I can't say that
I push for color when
I'm feeling like
it's inappropriate
or it's not serving
the characters well.
Am I answering your
question correctly?
It's not-- no,
there's no correct.
But I guess, I just
wanted to assume,
because I think what
casting directors do,
and I think this is really
a chance that people hear
about this, is offer,
again, a point of view,
I think of as being as much
an artistic pursuit as costume
or makeup or anything else.
You guys have tried
to offer, as you were
saying, supporting a vision.
But again, I guess kind
of arguing against a fixed
point of view, and knowing how
hard that is for you to do,
and Vicky was talking
about the side door thing.
Sometimes making a suggestion
that nobody was expecting.
If you feel that kind of
freedom as often as not?
I mean, we have chemistry
reads sometimes to bring some,
you know, to bring
some of those fears--
to sort of temper those.
But if we don't have
access to actors
that are going to actually come
in and do chemistry reads--
I don't know, I think
casting directors,
there's a certain leap of
faith and a sixth sense
that we have when
we feel something
is really going to work.
And I'm usually very
passionate about something
that I feel strongly about.
And I will fight
it till the end.
And if I lose, then
you know, I tried.
But it is usually the director's
vision that I'm servicing.
So I know my place, and
I'm going to just serve up
my best options to him.
And ultimately, it's his choice.
Although I do think
things can get very--
I think directors lives
when prepping a movie,
being in the middle of
preproduction, I mean,
it's just very hectic.
There's a lot of
different questions
coming at them, different
departments pulling on them.
And I think it's
good to remind them
of something that
can kind of get lost
in that whole maelstrom
of preproduction,
of having a million people
asking you questions.
If we could just help
them keep their eye
on the prize, so to speak,
like it can kind of be--
I remember Michael Mann
once said to me, he said--
I asked him what it was.
He says, I just want to
take a mental diuretic,
because there's just so much--
just you know, he was
in the midst of it all.
And hopefully, on some level,
like every department head can
kind of, just while
someone's about to,
you know, they're
against all these walls,
that we can just
help remind them
of what they were
trying to achieve,
if it tends to go a
little bit off course,
if they need to remember.
Now, remember, you
said you wanted
this or that, or da, da, da.
You know, just try to be there
to, like every other department
head, to help refocus
sometimes, and re-remind.
And I think, you know,
in the case of casting,
because you are casting--
you know, reading many
people for different roles,
and like Vicky said, this
is all interlaced with all
the other things
that you're doing,
you know, it's always good to
have a casting director to tell
you everyone you've cast in the
secondary professional roles is
a woman in her 30s.
Or everyone you've cast
in the medical professions
is a Latino.
So again, a reminder of
what the whole picture looks
like, even beyond--
obviously, it's just
a reminder, does
what we're doing here reflect
the world that the story takes
place in, the world
that you live in,
the world that you
want to reflect?
And that doesn't mean you have
to have a rainbow of colors.
But I think that's where the
casting director is crucial,
giving you--
reminding you of
the lay of the land.
This is where we are right now.
This is where we are.
This is what it looks
like, from an age, sex,
sexual orientation, color, you
know, ethnicity, et cetera.
[INAUDIBLE] briefly a question.
I'm going to start with you,
and ask [INAUDIBLE] these guys.
Talk to me about your
first conversation
as a casting director
on your first movie,
and how your eyes were kind of
opened to exactly the things
they're talking about?
Well, I am always
playing you first.
People are eager to ask the
director for their idea,
and I'm always to not give it.
I'm always like, you read
the script, you tell me.
What did you think?
What did-- and I
want to hear that
from casting directors and
anyone in every department,
including the actors.
If an actor asks me,
what's your script about?
I would say, what do
you think it's about?
You want-- here's the thing.
I feel that all departments
and all creative people,
they work from their
imagination, from their talent,
from their experience.
I'm always reluctant to say--
sometimes a casting
director will say to me
right off the bat,
in the ideal world,
who would your ideal
three actors be?
And I'm like, no, let
us surprise ourselves.
You tell me, you
know what I mean?
It's like, I'm reluctant
to say what I think.
I'm reluctant to be
trapped in my own thing.
And listen, I see it not just
with myself, but with directors
who are friends, or
directors that I know,
and including some
of the greatest
directors in the world.
They had this idea, and then
in the end it wasn't the idea,
and they were thrilled
that it wasn't the idea.
So it's, again, it's what do you
think ends up being something
that as a director you should
be asking a lot, I think.
In my not so humble opinion.
[LAUGHTER]
I like [INAUDIBLE] to
a lack of humility.
That's always, always good.
[INAUDIBLE],, let
me ask you, Vicky,
do you remember
your first casting
job and what that
was like, and how
you were able to sort
of make breakthroughs,
and kind of what's
that entail for you?
My first casting job
was on a student film
that became a feature film.
And so I didn't kind of go
through a traditional route.
I didn't go through working
for a casting director,
being an assistant.
And so I kind--
and my first one,
I wouldn't really
consider kind of being
a part of the industry.
It was just--
Hollywood, it was kind
of an independent film
that we all kind
of got together.
Let's make a movie.
And then somebody gave
us more money to make it.
Oh, we're making a feature.
So it's kind of, just thrown
into the deep end of the pool,
and just learn to
swim, you know?
Yeah.
So it didn't really
have anything
to do with the
business in a way.
It kind of had to do
more with film school,
and an independent
group of people.
And I just kind of
went on instincts
I've had just watching tons
of movies and television shows
growing up.
And kind of always
taking note of actors,
and knowing which
actors I liked,
and not really planning
to kind of do this job.
But once it got
thrown at me, it was
a skill set that I kind of had
and didn't quite know I had.
So I had a sense of actors very
early on that I saw growing up.
And I just kind of
referred to that
in my first casting meeting
and my first casting job.
In some ways, what
you're saying is
you could have basically
had an affinity for this,
and you didn't realize it
until you started doing it.
Yes, I did.
And I actually had an
affinity for growing up.
I just wasn't being
a casting director.
I was being a movie addict
and a television addict,
and you know, loving all
the TV shows and the actors,
and I just had an
affinity for them.
So yeah, I found out I
had an affinity for it.
Yeah.
And Julie, what
was your first job,
like in your first
conversation with a director
about getting actors cast?
The one I can recall,
one of my early
like doing it on my own jobs,
it came with an actor that was
somewhat established attached.
And that was thrilling.
The filmmaker had nurtured his
own relationship with an actor,
and an independent
film certainly
can use all the help it can get.
So to have an actor that
other actors respected--
I mean, he wasn't
a household name,
but he was a working actor,
and he was doing good work.
And so it was Jeremy Sisto.
And then through being
able to promote and talk
about the project with
him on board already,
it really helped--
I realized how much it
facilitated and attracted
other actors that wanted
to work with Jeremy.
And so, you know,
talking to agents
and having them tell you that
their client is just coming out
in something that's
going to be huge,
and it would be such a coup
to have them in your film,
and just kind of
like seeing that it
was a little bit of a selling
relationship with the agent,
with the reps and us,
and being able to feel
all the different
ideas being thrown,
it was a really exciting
and cool learning experience
to be able to put
the pieces together.
And also to have all these
names be thrown at you
and to be able to say, you
know, they're not right.
So that was kind of
an interesting thing
to have these ideas
and talent options,
but to really service the story
and work with the director
and say, well, this big
name was pitched to us,
but I don't think they're right.
So that was kind of a
interesting aspect to our job.
How did it feel when you
first said that, Julia?
The first time you said it.
It was actually like, I felt--
I mean, it's not
like a power thing,
but I think I felt
really like this
is the job that I'm meant
to do because I really
love what I do.
And it's not about names.
It's not about movie stars.
It's about the story, and it's
about working collaboratively
with the director.
So it was good.
It was a good feeling.
So let me ask you something that
I want to ask everybody anyway,
and now is a good time
as any to be talking
about this, about the movies
or TV shows that make you think
there's a place for
me in this world,
because that's kind of key,
and it's the sort of thing,
you're all talking about this
love affair for this medium,
and this connection with talent.
And I just wondered
if there are things
that you saw as kids
that make you think,
I could be in this place.
I could do what these
people are doing.
There will be some entree
for me here, even though
as people of color, obviously,
that wasn't always the case.
But you have to sort of
almost will it for yourself,
for ourselves anyway.
I wonder what those examples
would be for you guys?
I mean, I grew up
in Mexico City.
So I did not feel that
sense of exclusion,
meaning there was a film
industry that it was quite big.
And then there were Hollywood
movies and American TV shows,
and that just seemed
so remote, you know?
I didn't even feel
excluded from it.
It just-- that's like watching
movies from another planet.
But I came here to the American
Film Institute in the '80s,
and I was a cameraman back then.
And the idea of
Mexican cinematographer
was beyond exotic here.
It was almost eyebrow raising.
Although Guillermo Navarro was
already making his way slowly,
but well.
But yeah, that
was-- you know, I've
had the pleasure of seeing
how that has changed,
and how the day
came when you said,
oh, I need you to see the work
of a Mexican cinematographer,
people would lean in.
After Navarro and Rodrigo
Prieto, Chivo Lubezki,
all those guys.
But luckily,
growing up, I didn't
feel that sense of exclusion
from beyond the industry
that I-- in the country
where I was growing up.
But you said something, and
it's still something that you--
some ambtion that's
sort of stoked
in you seeing these movies
coming from this other planet
that you were talking about,
that seemed kind of remote,
and so I wondered what those
things would have been?
It felt very remote, but
only because it was far away
and in another country, and not
because I felt it excluded me
as a result of my ethnicity,
culture, or color, I mean,
to be frank, because
you know, it's--
I wasn't in that world.
But yes, it was it was
extremely remote, honestly.
I don't think, you
know, for any of us--
and by us, I mean that
generation of Mexican directors
who's working here in
Hollywood, and which
includes some of the greatest
filmmakers of the moment.
You know, none of us really
thought we would even
have an international career.
The ambition was to
make movies in Mexico.
So I guess there was a
psychological barrier,
that even if you're not
being told no you can't, we
were telling
ourselves it's going
to be really hard to get there.
So yes, I think, I'm
backpedaling already.
There was a psychology of
I could never get there,
you know?
But I'm sure young
people must have felt it
in St. Louis, Missouri, just
Hollywood seemed a planet away.
But also there were
things being beamed
from that planet, if I may
torture a metaphor here,
of movies or things that you
saw that you think, yeah,
I can do this.
There's a place for me.
I just wonder if, what
some of those were.
You know, I actually,
the neorealists,
you know, the
Italians, because they
were telling stories of working
people, middle class people.
The actors were not
necessarily beautiful.
They were not Hollywood people.
A lot of them were non-actors.
So I would say that watching all
those Italian neorealist movies
made you think, oh, wow, OK.
Well, that looks
like people that
could be like us, like people
from Mexico City, middle class,
working class.
I think that's the closest
thing to say, oh, OK.
It doesn't all have
to be Hollywood.
It could be this.
And is there-- were movies like
that for you as well, Julia,
or things that make you
think, well, I could do this,
or there's a place for me here?
Well, born and
raised in Los Angeles
does not mean it's an automatic
in to the town's industry.
I did feel--
I mean, it wasn't
uncommon for me
to be the only person
of color in an office.
But I did feel--
I never felt hyper
aware of that.
I did feel a sense
of belonging, and I
gravitated towards like weird
movies, like David Lynch
and just--
I liked that there were voices
that were not exactly making
sense, and they were
just kind of marching
to their own drummer.
And so I was like, oh,
I'll join that club please.
I feel like I can work
with people like that.
So yeah.
I think I definitely felt
like there was a place for me.
And those are the kind of
filmmakers you are still
working with, people who
hear those weird voices
in their head, that they want
to get on that screen, right?
Yeah, that'll never change.
[LAUGHS]
For sure.
What about you, Vicky?
What what are some of
the things that you
saw being such a consumer
of this kind of stuff?
What made you think, well,
God, I could be in this.
I could do this kind of thing.
Because I think, I just want
to get this out to young people
watching this who do have
these kinds of questions,
or even growing up, as you
said, living in Los Angeles,
you still, if you grew
up here, doesn't mean
you're in the movie business.
So Vicky, I'm just
wondering what
those things would be for you.
You know, I grew up in LA too.
My dad worked at
the post office.
My mom sold encyclopedia.
We were nowhere near
Hollywood in terms
of being near that profession.
But I just always, I never--
I mean, everything I saw told
me I could work in the industry.
I didn't say anything
that told me I couldn't.
I mean, I just--
and I looked at every type of
movie, all types of TV shows.
I think, mainly my
parents never told us
we couldn't not do something.
So for me, wanting to be in show
business seemed to make sense.
And I didn't really
look at any obstacles.
Because I'm asking
this just because you
guys are all
extraordinarily successful.
And again, I think what's
so interesting about you,
you all have very
specific points of view.
And being in a business
that is often as not,
doesn't seem to
welcome points of view,
just the position to be
filled, what it's like for you
to continue to try to work
as artists in the field?
That's the fun part.
I mean, you know, yeah.
I mean, I'd love to bring
a point of view to it,
but I don't know that--
even with something
that's typically
Hollywood, a big budget
Hollywood blockbuster,
hopefully you can infuse
something with the casting
or whatever that kind of
helps give it a little tweak
and make it a little
more interesting than a,
let's say a normal Hollywood
big blockbuster movie.
I'm just using something, those
are kind of generic terms.
But yeah, hopefully just
bring a point of view
to whatever you're working on.
And hopefully there's room in
it to bring your point of view.
Sometimes there's not, and
you kind of-- you kind of have
to, OK, this is what--
say this is what this is.
And OK-- you just kind of
take a step back a little bit.
You fight the fight
as much as you can.
And sometimes you don't
always win those fights,
or people don't always want to--
they just want to kind of make
the generic product in a way,
you know?
So sometimes your point of
view is appropriate to things,
and it may be less
appropriate to other things,
if that makes any sense?
No, it does.
It is what I was asking you.
Yeah, thank you.
I wonder if that--
has that been the
case for you ever,
Rodrigo, when you
felt that [INAUDIBLE]..
You know, I always say to
younger writer directors,
or writers, or
directors, you know,
if you have some success
when you're starting,
you have to be careful
that you're not
being paid not to be an
artist, because you do
get paid not to be an artist.
Sometimes if you're a young
up and coming screenwriter,
they'll pay you a lot of money
to rewrite a script in a way
that it's safe and
really not great.
But that's what
you're being paid for.
You're being paid
not to be an artist.
Don't bring your dreams, your
nightmares, your sickness
into a project.
Just write me a pretty picture.
So yes, you have to be
careful that you're not
leaning into that.
And you know, yeah,
to Vicky's point,
you have to voice your opinion.
You're also hired
for your opinion.
They may or may not
pay attention to it.
But you have to do it.
And I think in
some cases, that's
why often directors become
famous for being difficult,
and certainly some heads of
department, and of course,
it's very commonly said with
women heads of department,
she's difficult. No,
she's not difficult.
She's telling you what
she thinks because that's
what you hired her for.
So that's-- but you know, that's
a problem in this industry
and in many industries.
Do you want to speak up or do
you just want to get along?
Yeah, I mean, I think,
there are directors
who have never compromised,
like David Lynch, for example,
and all the power to him.
But he, like Orson Welles
and many other greats,
found it increasingly
difficult to make movies,
because they did not compromise.
So it's also a life choice.
What about for you, Julia?
Have you been in
situations where it's--
you're trying to fight
against the idea of it being
a product when you see
something more in the material,
and I just wonder how
you deal with that?
I've been fortunate to have very
minimal experience with that.
When I meet-- when a
material is presented to me
and I read a script,
I spark to the ones
that I can see myself
contributing something artistic
to it.
I gravitate towards
something that's unique,
and I gravitate
towards directors
that have a collaborative
spirit that are
open to me saying what I feel.
And I haven't had
a lot of experience
where I had to fight.
I've, like I said, I haven't
won every battle of a casting
choice that I've presented.
But I've had a lot of--
I've had a lot of good
fortune with the projects
that I've worked on.
And it's someone intentional.
I have to love the
material and feel
like there's something I can add
to what's already on the page.
Was that the case with The Last
Black Man In San Francisco?
Absolutely.
Yes.
It's unique.
It grabbed me from the start.
The people behind it,
I could tell it just,
they were so
passionate about it,
and it was super infectious.
And I just really wanted
to fulfill their vision
to make them happy, for sure.
In a situation like
that, it's been,
we're talking about
for me, things
you guys have in
common is you guys
tend to be really good
at creating communities.
And that San
Francisco, that movie
felt like a real place and
not the real San Francisco,
if you will.
It felt like its own thing.
And I think that idea of
creating a world that feels
lived in but distinctive
is what you want to do.
Yeah.
I really credit those guys.
There's really not
an inauthentic beat.
You know, maybe there
had to be for some--
like Danny Glover even,
he's a commercial actor,
and sometimes I'm
not always keen
on having so someone well known
play a character, because it
might take you out of
the story, and then
the authenticness
of the story is--
it suffers a little bit.
But he's from the Bay Area.
He is a beloved person
from the communities
that the story is about.
He had deep knowledge of
what the story was about.
And he really sparked
to it as well,
so it felt like a logical
marriage for sure.
And for you, Vicky, your first
conversation with Quentin
Tarantino, you
guys must have felt
you've know each other
your entire lives.
Yes.
[LAUGHS]
I think we were, like we grew
up in the same household, just
like 20 miles away, you know,
South Bay and and South LA.
Yeah, it was kind of, yeah,
brother from another mother.
It was, yeah.
We were the two same
nerdy kids growing up.
So I felt an
affinity, definitely.
There's also the
thing, too, again,
talking about creating
real communities.
What does that feel even
like [INAUDIBLE] behind you?
You've got to build
out something, well,
Once Upon A Time In
Hollywood, that feels bigger
than life, but not [INAUDIBLE].
And that must have
been sort of the thrill
and the challenge of that.
Yeah, I mean, I grew up in LA,
going to Hollywood Boulevard,
taking the bus.
Or my dad would drop
me and my friends off.
And I remember the events
of the movie happening.
It's just one I wanted to really
get right, kind of you know.
And yeah, it's
kind of heightened
but very realistic
at the same time.
And yeah, it was just a--
yeah, that was special one.
I have a girlfriend that worked
with him at the video store
that he worked at.
He knew every title.
He knew every shelf.
That's what she told me.
Yeah.
But I mean, this is so, and
this is for you too, Rodrigo.
I mean, this idea of
creating something that feels
real and bigger than life.
Because so often movies tend
to be these divided things,
they're either one or the other.
And I think that
kind of specificity
that that kind of
creation demands
is something you saw
in those neorealists,
and something that you want to
bring to the screen as well,
isn't it?
Yeah, I mean,
especially if you're
making contemporary, realistic,
psychological dramas,
how do you give it some
pop without it turning
into something that it's not?
Not too flat, not too poppy.
I mean, I'd say a
movie like, is it
The Farewell, the one with
the dying grandmother?
I don't want to give-- yes.
And that was, I thought that was
a very particular world, a very
particular tone,
and yet really just
a middle class family
Chinese, Chinese-Americans.
But it managed to
do that, create
that sort of slightly
heightened but totally grounded.
I think casting can do that.
It's always tricky
because like Julia said,
it's you're always scared,
oh, can I mix this star
with these mortals?
Is that going to be-- is
there going to be glue?
But there's also
a reason why stars
are stars, is because
they are great actors
and they fit in
beautifully into movies.
I mean, I've been
in that situation,
fortunately, where
I'm like, no, no, I
can't mix these two
new people with this--
but it works.
You're trying to achieve
that, something heightened
and special without your casting
being artificial and forced.
I think that's a
constant battle, I think.
I think that's a constant,
whether you're mixing lesser
knowns and well-known people.
Just you're always-- you
want to walk that fine line.
And I don't think that ever goes
away for a casting director,
no matter how long
you cast, you know?
You're always just trying
to get that balance right,
and just making sure that
you're keeping something real,
and as Julia said,
will the addition
of that big name in this small
part do this, or I don't know.
I've been constantly
surprised when, no, it
doesn't all the time.
It's just-- but the
tensions are always there.
I always get a little nervous.
I think it's a little
nerve wracking,
I think, for all
casting directors.
No matter how long
you've been doing it.
Is that the fun of it that's
a little anxiety producing?
It's definitely anxiety--
I mean, it's anxiety
producing, and I mean,
it's almost like
you ask yourself,
did I just start
casting yesterday,
because how come I don't
feel better about this?
Or how come I don't know?
That's the thing.
Don't you know this by now?
You know, it's yeah.
Well, you did it beautifully in
Once Upon a Time In Hollywood.
That was a big order to fill.
And I got lost in this story.
So kudos to you guys.
Thank you.
Kudos to you.
And I think part
of that that fear
that Vicky is talking about, you
never recuperate from a casting
mistake.
I mean, it really is a knife
in your side forever and ever.
And it has nothing-- and
it doesn't necessarily
have anything to do with casting
stars and non-stars, actors
and non-actors.
Because you can have
the right level of fame
but still cast the
role that you're like,
oh, no, that was the wrong
tone, or she was too young,
he was too old.
You know, casting
can be traumatic,
because once you
cast the role, it's
going to be that face,
that body, that voice,
that instrument
forever and ever.
So it can be preoccupying,
to put it mildly.
It's a heavy burden.
[LAUGHS]
I have no doubt.
You make me so anxious
talking about it here,
and I don't even do it.
But I guess, as we're
talking about this too,
this made me go back to thinking
about the most recent USC
Annenberg study about
inclusion, again.
We're talking about
trying the idea
for you guys of
creating art but not
ignoring where the world is.
And I guess, I really wonder
if this feels like it's--
there's actual
momentum behind these,
the changes that
we're seeing now,
because I thought about
this a couple weeks ago,
unfortunately, when
Chadwick Boseman passed,
that in the light of that
movie, where has there
been this search to say, well,
that worked less than something
else I've played.
It still feels to me like when
movies with casts of color
succeed, they feel anomalous,
rather than part of a wave.
And I just wonder how you
guys deal with that feeling
if [INAUDIBLE]?
Well, no matter how
much you might bring up
something that disproved
a notion, a film,
a particular film, or a
particular actor or whatever,
I don't know, it's like
people, they just, they forget.
You can quote situations where,
well, this movie did well
in Europe, even though it has
an all black cast, or whatever.
And it's like, [INAUDIBLE],, it's
not going to sell in Europe,
or whatever it is.
So I think there
are lessons learned
and then they're
quickly unlearned.
So I think it's kind of
a constant battle, kind
of going back--
you just need another
example and another example
and another example till
maybe something will stick.
But I don't think
that's always the case.
And it's an ongoing thing.
I mean, it's easy
right now to say
that what the Academy has
done is in a moment of,
just to put an example, it's in
a moment of Black Lives Matter.
But not really.
I mean, it's been, you
know, it's been five,
six, seven years since
the Academy has started
its inclusion with
membership and stuff,
because it is an ongoing thing.
I mean, the fact, the idea that
one thing is going to solve it,
you know, the Civil Rights
was 50 years ago plus.
So it's ongoing.
And pay attention,
because it's not
just what the Academy
is asking you to do.
But you know, don't be on
the wrong side of history.
Sure.
Julia, do you have any
thoughts about that too?
I just wondered what
it feels like to you?
Well, I don't know how--
I mean, the survey
was a large span.
I think it was like
from '07 to recently.
And I don't really
agree with that survey,
because I see the changes around
me, having just watched the US
Open and seeing Naomi Osaka win,
a biracial woman representing
Japan, and happens
to live in LA.
And of course, Serena
opened the doors,
and that was like 29 years ago.
It's a predominantly
white sport,
and now there's so much color.
I think that it's--
I see it happening, and I
pooh pooh the naysayers.
I think that I see
representation on screen.
And I do think there's
more work to be done.
But I think we're headed
in the right direction.
And I do think things like
the Academy's requirements
hold us accountable, keep
the conversation going,
and panels like this keep
the conversation going.
And that's all a good thing.
Well, that's probably a
great point to end on.
Let me thank you guys
so much for doing this.
I could really talk about
this for a whole lot longer,
but nobody [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you guys so much.
Thanks, Elvis.
Hi, I'm Julia Kim.
Thank you for watching our
Academy Dialogues conversation.
Check out previous discussions,
and subscribe to the Oscars
channel for more videos.